[Musique]
les samoa le calendrier 2010 est de
bâtir j'habite à et bien le calendrier
il est sorti alors on va on va regarder
un petit peu parce que ya deux ans la
regarder ça et enfin les chroniqueurs
ont voulu refaire un petit peu les pose
donc vous allez voir chez vous ce que ça
donne ça c'est batista a bah oui ça
aurait ça alors ça c'est toujours
baptiste et ouais voilà dieu bénisse le
paysage est beau
non mais c'est vrai très beaux paysages
merci ingrid chauvin quoi la police in
gratuit
[Applaudissements]
baptiste voilà donc c'est le maquis
derrière c'est la rolls immersive ce que
vous voulez vous une grille à excuser
moi quoi non je disais que caroline
avait aussi porté cette robe de façon
très jolie au ralenti alors on est
directement soit en warning là on a le
triangle à 57 on est tranquille on a le
gilet jaune on attend les dépanneurs
koné souffre alors oui oui
alléchant trucages et sa page avant il
épaulera qui ont trop et c'est vraiment
toi regarder mais bien sûr que c'est lui
il n'y a pas de trucage un nom
quoi qu'est ce qu'il a fait pour être in
témoin comme apprécié le soutien gorge
mais c'est vrai que avait eu là vous
n'avez même pas la poitrine de
maintenance et incident technique ne
permette non mais il est beau j'avais
mal au sabre baptiste non s'écouler vous
qui connaissait la beauté ouais il est
bien ont ils vont bien le temps filant
le torse et ebook tout lui est bon tout
je connais il fait déjà beaucoup
d'équitation alors celui-là ça c'est dur
à faire sa déposition
les muscles à rennes on n'envoie pas les
défauts autrefois de contorsionniste moi
tu fais pas le grand kabar et offrir à
décoller il est bien là dessus baptistin
et on voit bien là reste je vais pas les
mettre les deux là comme récemment c'est
pas la même séquence entreprises et le
pantalon qui n'avait tous en pole à laon
passe pas le même mois de septembre
autour de vins corses y arriver ils sont
contents et la habiballah ça vous tombe
sur le coin de la gueule c'est pas la
même c'est pas lui même déjà la
prochaine photo ah ouais ça une bonne
souris se prend la tête là il était sur
un contrôle de maths et de ziff +26
c'est beau c'est un talibé recette
préférée c'est celle d'un grand change
tu as raison mais si aujourd'hui je veux
dire le monde de la coiffure échangeons
[Applaudissements]
et
comme beaucoup elle est bien ça vous
fait rire à mathieu que vous en pensez
je préfère écrit non mais non non mais
en plus c'est comme il est mannequin
aussi j'ai appris ça y'a pas longtemps
voilà ccl2 de styles différents et c'est
le style de bancal voilà rien mannequin
le de jabba c'est la photo la plus
récente médecin mais c'est franchement
c'est baptiste après avoir passé deux
mois chez ma mère ne regarde pas le
cerveau après le trouble est également
là il a man les far hills et démonter
quoi c c'est françois hollande avant
d'être président et maintenant à
l'aironi m'a jamais été très bon comme
ça toi tu le sais très bien où la sallaz
je veux pas savoir qu'il appelle je vais
permanent je vois bien un match attendu
en vain
mal c'est pas mal mieux
aujourd'hui à moins de jean sérien poil
face à un point ça s'enlève se mit à mal
les abdos quand même les abdos sont
beaux à prix là il c'est vrai que là des
petites jambes en danger tout ce qui est
en bas et pout tout ce qui est en haut
et bien c'est en bas ça part en
cacahuète pour il est mort je sens vous
allait ralentir le rythme non non je
voulais savoir si mathieu s'épilait pour
ne pas avoir de poste régis humilie moi
j'ai pas de poils d'après boire c'est
jamais venu mais les bienvenus ça me
vient voile à wayne mais à ce point
quand même y'a pas toi le terrain alors
celui-là as well as il faut être deux
pour la tête et là c'est quand il
attendait le bus à cette seule gagner
comme ça on entend le son mythe
je vais vous oblitéré c'est parti
regarde c'est qui a way a well as oui il
attend le bus pour rentrer à la maison
de retraite mais jours mais parfois ça
passe écosystèmes à 57 du qatar ouais
ouais ouais on en a lui même dernière ah
oui ça là c'est la meilleur série c'est
toi c'est une fois que vous savez j'ai
pas le temps de le faire
ouais ouais tu pas j'ai beaucoup de
travail
[Applaudissements]
sur la table a connu la même chose
las de ce côté là on a un mec il ne faut
pas s'il va faire un football américain
et la bonne tu tires ou tu pointes
cautionner le mondial de pétanque mozart
sous une chaleur tropicale
le cochonnet virevolte c'est thierry
moreau qui va s'élancer m'étais bien
non mais franchement haïti tignes c'est
pas mal ils allaient paix qu'à
l'intérieur
ouais ouais en fait là son corps qui
veut se barrer il a le 100 m c'est son
corps il va vite mais je donne ma région
les boosterait merci et c'est le
contraire de kim kardashian
non mais c'est vrai elle est d'aller en
toile et là là et là c'est tout est
rentré rentrée en lui mais thierry est
mais je vous jure à vous aussi vous êtes
pas mal c'est bien mais j'en fais on
rigole mais il est pas mal joué mais
c'est non
thierry je vous jure je trouve qu'il ya
un truc quoi là je sais pas encore bah
c'est pas milliards atteint c'est pas
bouteilles d'eau les cherry on a cru
qu'on allait y est vous avez pas fait
une photo vous si vous tombez alors
attendez un oui à la boire à trois bien
sûr également away à oui ça ils ont fait
regarder et regarder que les soldats il
ya un truc aussi n'ont rien car
franchement lé byin rayons elle est
belle franchement clics vous avez vous
avez qui fait drôle de coco
si vous avez qui fait le connais on vous
écoute
[Applaudissements]